we can help you sad come on come over
here we've got girls girls who want to
meet you girls in your town girls sign
up you can meet girls like girls what
kind of girls you know it's like someone
someone offering you food Facebook's new
online dating service won't have ads I
thought that said won't have aids like
what the [ __ ] are they saying it sounds
like that'll take advantage of what
you're talking about right now you know
online dating service won't have ads so
but it will have Russians all Russians
all the time well I mean it'd be nice of
people you just meet people in the real
world
just meeting people online stuff it's so
weird how like I talk to people that use
tender they hook up on tinder like
weekly and there's a lot of these people
that that's all they do they'll just
[ __ ] people on tinder all day and it
just makes me wonder how many people
just do that like oh you old data women
and she's already been [ __ ] like seven
times from you know you're the same app
you know like all these we were just
like they're just like you're taking
extreme risks yeah with your VD it was
there was the [ __ ] thing where they
wanted to sue online dating apps like
someone was saying should online dating
apps be responsible for the increase in
sexually transmitted diseases
should they be responsible like as if
they have some obligation to tell you to
wear a rubber how [ __ ] stupid that is
like some they have some obligation
there like you know like look you you
know these poor little children are no
[ __ ] you need to tell them they need
to protect themselves like these broad
alts grown adults using an app tinder
and Grindr don't want to talk about
their role in rising STDs good why do
you want to talk to them you muckraking
piece of [ __ ] they don't have a role
they connect people together people make
their own decisions you got to be
responsible for your own action
especially when it comes to something
like that that's crazy and you know the
other part is like the demonization of
sex is a big part of this or what about
tinder and cryo
what are you doing here's all those
people just having sex and getting STDs
you're responsible what about your part
what about your role you get out of here
that's ridiculous that's ridiculous
do bars have a role in liver splices
should they pay people out
should they be financially responsible
they're literally selling you the [ __ ]
that kills you and they have zero
responsibility as long as they don't
serve you while you're drunk and driving
long as they cut you off in time and say
hey I got too drunk we cut them off all
right sounds good they literally sell
you the stuff that does it to you and no
one cares as they should no one should
care you're [ __ ] grown adult this
grinder those are dudes banging each
other all day do you think that anyone's
gonna stop that oh oh I shouldn't
connect these people you should make
money connecting them you shouldn't give
them the opportunity to do exactly what
they want as grown adults with a limited
amount of time on earth you got 90 years
if you're lucky if you wanna spend 45 of
them raw dog and dudes you go you go boy
who gives a [ __ ]
are they response they don't want to
talk about that responsibility shut the
[ __ ] up babies now that bad very excited
about something especially Grindr now
that Backpage is closed like all these
web sites are closing it's very
interesting to see what happens next
where people are gonna find their
hookups and stuff well yeah that was so
what I was reading this thing where sex
workers are in danger because of this
because before they used to be able to
vet customers and then customers would
have like a record of using other sex
workers and they could know who the
psychos were and who to avoid you know I
mean and they could also screen people
like actively screen they could do they
could do all this they were saying I was
it was reading an article about it where
this girl who remember if they gave her
name out or not but she was she worked
in a brothel
and she was talking about it
and it's like what why are they doing
this
like is there is it because of a crime
like what's the crime so if they get
together like through tinder or Grindr
that's fine because that's two people
that decide to have sex but as long as
they're grown adults and one person just
wants to get paid and the other person
is like wha pay yeah and they go okay
fine
like what why is that illegal like we're
not talking about sex trafficking for
children we're not talking about slavery
we're talking about just let's just look
at it from the cleanest perspective
possible grown adult who likes sex
decides she wants to work in a brothel
is that possible is it possible for you
to do that like to for it to be a grown
adult who actually enjoys it doesn't
have any problem with it decides that
it's better than working at Wendy's
isn't that pop is that possible I mean
that people don't want to say it nobody
wants to say that it's possible nobody
wants to ever look at it that way the
war on sex workers needs to stop now
rolling stone yeah yeah it's it just
seems like a dumb thing to chase down I
mean I think if people want to have sex
with each other nobody has a problem
with it but if people want to pay people
to have sex then it's a problem that
seems so crazy again we're not talking
about child slavery we're not talking
about sex slaves we're not talking about
anything against anybody's will we're
just talking about people who would
choose to do that like why not
and I've always used this example but
it's a good example why why isn't it
okay for me to get a massage so okay for
me to pay someone to give me pleasure
all over my body except my genitals like
they could rub my neck and my feet and
getting all all up in my feet man to get
those thumbs and start working your
finger uh they crack your toe pop pop it
feels great that's fine but they can't
jerk you off they jerked you off that
would be a terrible sin against God and
man if they touched your penis which
feels really good when you touch it
can't do that I know a dude who said he
gets ass hole massages yeah that
actually happens all the time interior
of your [ __ ] they must
the interior of your [ __ ] that's okay
because it's just a massage prostate
massage what's weird is when they do it
and they don't ask you because that a
lot of massage people just do it that's
a part of the massage and they just
start yeah but no no I don't want that
apparently some people get it where they
use a tool and they actually go in side
your ass hole and rub down no no no
that's a tool the other one fist they
use some sort of thing to [ __ ] check
your butt that's okay that's fine that's
fine just don't touch the dick if you
touch the dick it's goddamn crime
they're waiting outside the door with a
pistol you just let me know when he
touches the dick and he's just rubbing
his [ __ ]
check the books son all right oh it's
Dick's not even hard okay okay we're
ready we're ready we're gonna break into
this [ __ ] shade place as soon as we
find out that he's dick touched you
could get someone to just massage your
[ __ ] just get in there with squeeze
your butt cheeks and get two thumbs in
your [ __ ] and what am i doing I'm
doing a sphincter massage it's very
important to release some of the chakras
and negative energy and and and some of
the toxins that are stored in your body
from processed foods and modern
lifestyle so we're just going in your
[ __ ] but to dump some guru let's talk
people into thumbing them in the ass